right y'all wanted to do is give money
bag joke with on the rocks finally let
is the word figure when I was coming up
like trying to get home but you
understood that you had to had an image
like as a reference the artist just
ahead attention you got it you can't
just walk in the room playing nobody
know who you is you're saying you're
artist like you really got it look you
got a turn here
shut up vagina dine get my mouth to feed
you kind of like gave me this as a gift
I got PG in the middle of breaking my
leg I had told him to make me a
championship range and this is what he
came up with I got the star power ring
it's coming from our icebox probably
like 12 I felt like 25 is I just for ice
boxes where they gave me this is a gift
you know a lot going on like windows
audience at the camp for ice box I wear
like six rings at one time I'm winning
so you know I probably lost two brains
it was like baguettes
I caught a baguette II ahead like the
canary stones in the middle and the
tooth on the side had like like widened
invisible set on the side it was super
hard and then wanted to raise my
daughter hair lost so she they just go
on there like when they see you set it
down who get in the mirror gonna act
like me not America it's another special
piece to meet
ice ball to make these two on the
internet they were posting pictures of
me next to Michael Mayer like my face
making memes that it like it was a joke
so I just took the negative Amanda
positive so I had googled the picture so
this is like it's really a picture of
Google and agent I stood out they were
trying to put like rose gold on and I
feel like now you gotta come like had a
real mask is like exactly Heidi who like
feet 50,000 it was a love primate you
know didn't like home
he's my tween
if you got a WH on he's walking home you
got the address on the back to where I
used to be at 7:42 cane road it's in
Memphis it's outside I mean you know I
had copter rolls roof but it's like the
rows were selling but your hair put the
hood in the middle of the got this
people Johnny he gave it to me as a gift
as you can see you got the two rings on
the earrings that I actually work and
these emoji design come from my sink I
got out with frigid
it's called okay and on the cove on the
artwork is just like the hand like the
flesh now push down hand it took like
2025 2500 diamonds my car I like looking
inward from picture 5 6 mm now this one
actually icebox may differ but this
image is that this delay I'm sad to also
and I got like three of these like
different sizes different logos and it's
just one of the first logos
I stopped buzz down on but just just the
newest design and I got it in gold it
weird I feel like mixing it up sometimes
I do try colors like rolling ago I do
all along rose gold white yellow same
thing it's another a little small
pendant through the same thing you just
spilt out this time instead of the bee
gees the brand I just feel that yeah
[Music]
before to nuggets and is really heavy
that guy was on toe when I got this my
too heartless - I treated myself to this
could my brother he loved the diamonds
and he really got me into diamonds I
just do all this with him and you know
for me because I like it this way and
there's humor to play you can see like I
say yo but the money bet he's shaped in
the money but I got the night money bag
yo like in high school
I actually had like a lot of rap nights
like a lot of different rep night he's
like Lu yo when I took rap series on
life I need something different unique
and just on stick sort of people so I
just like [ __ ] on me you I'm gonna
use money back up 10:25 eat them all
Adie Cubans come from xboxes with you
just like you because I got gold I got a
white girl white cold and I got a solid
I got a tennis bracelet too
it's all all time this actor was a guilt
from my booking man he gave me this as a
gift for my birthday huh I got this from
Sanju will is like 80 it's got dual
two-tone roll it you can see like the
white on the side to yell to go down
bills a bus down and I got this black
face because when I worked when I rock
him to Michael Myers I got the black her
and she's kind of go with mine even
though the Tom pay attention to the time
on it I just shining hard look at this
ap right here push down come from Shia
to run out on the bill around side
ap they look like maybe looking like for
taste at me of the V but they got their
own the octagonal and type shape
sometimes I wear both of you watches at
the same time just on subscribe like
whatever
I got another piece on the way actually
Ilyana tape he just facetiming it's
afraid of cooler but my homeboy is night
we used to call him Fred Aroo but he
died thought he had dress up with the
Black Diamond dress on him
with the black head with the with the
whole hand and the he's crazy I'm gonna
bring that next time Jeep through
audience resit out right now everywhere
available
make sure you Tony and go get that this
year
[Music]